hello, how are you, sala aramillo greets you
with your brief informative for today monday
june 7 a fire was detected in the
other apartment complex near
the sahara and maryland on sunday
afternoon no one was injured but 22
people had to evacuate their
homes the fire  it began
around three in the afternoon on sunday
clark county is still investigating the cause of
this incident since this would not be the
first time that a fire has occurred in
these departments it is reported that
there have been at least four others
since 2007
the hockey team  from the golden knights they
tied the series a2 colorado opened the
scoring last night inside the cimov ordina
but then vigués come names turned
around with 5 scores including a
hat trick from janet in progress there are more than
18 thousand fans attended the by three
the largest number of people  so
far the m hl so far this
season the fifth game will be tomorrow
at six in the evening in denver
excited  s for the next one and says in
October of this year more than 200 artists have
already announced their presentations for the
great celebration after 10 years of
experience since such a popular
musical event james mo cristerna party
oscar kate stars are some of the
most recognized artists that will delight
to the public with their shows this party
will be at the speedway wall of las velas
from October 22 to 24
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a hot but
cloudy day with some winds with a
maximum of 97 degrees for today the temperatures will drop
for  the next few days
rolling 90 degrees
however we will see an increase for the
weekend with temperatures in the triple
digits beautiful days I am I left
Jaramillo and this was your brief
informative edition in Spanish
[Music]